- [Narrator] This is a chart
showing estimated population
around the year 1750
in the British colonies in the New World.
I've arranged this more or
less from north to south
and you can see that as
you go farther south,
the percentage of the population
that was enslaved and African
grew greater and greater,
but one thing to note here is that
not any one of these colonies
had zero enslaved people at all,
even New Hampshire, the farthest north
with the smallest percentage
of enslaved Africans
had some enslaved people there
before the American Revolution.
We frequently have the misconception
that slavery only happened in the south.
In fact, all British colonies
had some amount of slavery
and all British colonies
had some involvement
in the institution of slavery,
whether that was bankrolling
it as a financier,
growing food that was intended
for the slave colonies
in the West Indies that
didn't want to spare
even an acre of land to grow something
other than sugar, or
shipping enslaved Africans
by either owning or captaining the boats
of the middle passage.
In fact, one of the largest ports
where slaves entered the
North American colonies
and were sold at auction was
at Newport, Rhode Island.
But despite this, the largest
share of enslaved people
were in the southern colonies,
which focused on plantation agriculture.
So, Maryland, Virginia,
and then even farther south
into the British colonies
in the Caribbean.
In some of these southernmost colonies,
you can see that enslaved Africans
outnumbered white people by sometimes
quite a considerable amount.
As the enslaved population
in the colonies grew,
colonial governments began
passing more and more
restrictions on the
lives of enslaved people
and began codifying who
was or was not a slave.
For example, if a white
man and an enslaved woman
had a child together,
would that child be free
like her father or
enslaved like her mother?
What about the opposite case?
In Virginia in 1662, the
government passed a law
specifying that the
children of enslaved women
would follow the condition
of their mothers.
Other laws prevented
interracial relationships
and defined enslaved
Africans as chattel slaves,
which means personal property,
and as the personal
property of slave owners,
enslaved people had
little to no legal rights.
So, over the course of the 1600s,
slavery became stricter
and more exclusively defined by race.
The experience of being
enslaved was unimaginably
physically and emotionally taxing.
Since enslaved people
had no legal protections,
owners could maim or
even kill enslaved people
with little to no repercussion.
For women, life in slavery also meant
the constant threat and frequent reality
of rape at the hands of slave owners.
Religion, dance, music, and family
helped enslaved people deal with
the harsh realities of everyday life
and enslaved people also developed
both covert means of resisting slavery,
like, for example, breaking tools,
which made it more difficult to work,
or overt means of resisting slavery,
particularly in slave uprisings.
One of these, the Stono Rebellion in 1739
in South Carolina resulted in the deaths
of about 42 whites and about 44 blacks.
The South Carolina government
responded to the rebellion
by making slave codes even harsher.
I wanna finish by just
reiterating how central
the institution of slavery was
to not just some, but all
of the English colonies.
In the 19th century, Americans
would refer to slavery
as the peculiar institution,
meaning not so much
that it was strange,
but that it was specific
to the south part of the United States.
But slavery really wasn't
specific to the south part,
it was the bedrock of
the colonial economy,
not just in the south,
but in all the industries
that contributed to slavery
in the north as well,
those who financed, fed, shipped,
and even bought the products
made by enslaved people
created the economic prosperity
of the North American colonies.